on sait aussi ce qui s'est passé à l'
usine d'union carbide à institute aux
états unis
c'est une erreur humaine qui a provoqué
la fuite de produits chimiques
les précisions de piscia pts il aura
fallu attendre plus de cinq jours avant
d'obtenir une explication cohérente de
la fuite de gaz toxique qui s'est
produite dimanche dernier dans une usine
de la société union carbide une usine
spécialisée dans les pesticides est
situé dans la petite ville américaine
institute en virginie occidentale
la fuite avait provoqué
l'hospitalisation de 135 personnes
atteintes de nausées de troubles
respiratoires et de brûlures aux yeux
aujourd'hui le directeur du contrôle de
la pollution de l'état de virginie
affirme il s'agit d'une erreur
d'ouvriers qui ayant pompe et une cuve
qu'il croyait vide avait en fait inspiré
1900 litres d'un mélange toxique
ce mélange ainsi aspiré avait chauffé et
sous la pression alors exercé une valve
avait lâché répandant dans l'atmosphère
le bass pollueurs on remarquera que les
dirigeants de nine carbide qui avait
exclu tout risque d'accident grave en
occident après la catastrophe de bhopal
de décembre dernier est cette fois
silencieux refusant même de commenter
cette explication de la fuite